citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Erickson a long time are you close
to your personal friends oh wow he tried
to go too soon I wasn't done with the
intro yet sorry today today
timing today today we're watching
Elemental it's a Disney Pixar film and
I'm super stoked neither of us have seen
it nope when I go to Disney California
Adventure Pixar lion is my favorite oh I
didn't know that that's the only place I
want to buy any merch all the stuff from
all the movies that made me cry so much
that I won't want to watch again like up
I can't watch that again no no no but
it's a perfect film don't forget you
leave a like you leave a comment you
ring the bell
also thank you to prepper for editing
this edit this no not the edit the
reaction video he's doing it if you're
not already a patron you need to get on
it because if you are you get to watch
this full entire video reaction with me
and him commenting through the entire
movie sync up with your own copy we love
you so much and we're gonna start this
film
hang that what is this a new intro that
Waterfall oh this is a new Disney intro
yeah yeah I saw it on Little Mermaid oh
my God I haven't watched that film yet
so that's why this is awesome it's so
pretty
[Music]
that is pretty so pretty
we have watched so many animated things
together so many
elements
already wow all over the screen
put in a coat on the fire to keep it's
interesting hey maybe fire still gets
cold
whoa that's so pretty
[Music]
wowza holy junk that is a big sub
oh I believe this is yours oh thanks
what a neat way of transportation nice
oh that's lovely cloud things I love
them already
elephant City your names
great and how do we spell that
how about we just go with Bernie and
Cinder
nice wow oh welcome to element City
little racist
how cute though is his nose it's a stamp
as well I don't know it's kind of like
if Italians came up to me I'm like can't
remember that I'm just gonna call you
Mario and Luigi
my gosh they better build a land like
this at Disneyland or I'm gonna be
obsessed they better spend 100 billion
dollars they should
oh that's so awesome I love everything
about this land and it's pretty
beautiful
oh
except for when you ride the train and
like water spills on you constantly I
wouldn't like that but
water
I'm a curious
I like how that hasn't been a lot of
dialogue in this first few minutes yeah
dry leaves
oh
oh God that's difficult for them fire is
segregated dang
foreign
[Music]
welcome my Ember to your new life is
that her name that's such a pretty name
Ember you know I heard a good amount of
people said they weren't too jazzed by
the animation but I really like this I
like it I think it's cool or blue flame
hold all our traditions and give us
strength to burn breath hahaha
[Music]
oh the fireplace nice that's a great
name for a restaurant yeah it is I would
go there like all the time everything
here authentic then I've got to try the
cool nuts call nuts coming up
done good job
oh
all right cool someday the shot will all
be mine
when you are ready
oh my God they are like the Italians in
New York City
or Irish
please I got it cool
get out of here
yeah man
okay yeah
oh is he getting like weaker yeah it's
old now how about you take it today for
real yeah Amber you have to be ready at
this point how can I help you all of
this and the oh the sparklers are buy
one get one free that's right great I'll
just take the free one oh no
need to buy one to get one free
but I just want the free one were you
stupid come on man the customer is
always right not in this case
nope oh my goodness buddy her first one
uh oh she needs to control her temper
just take breath and make connection
when you can do that then you will be
ready to take over shop is that the
theme control your temper make
connection take breath make connections
okay she has a temper problem for sure
I don't know why that one got away from
me oh you are 10 times
oh that's awesome it's just some of
these customers they get me up I know
God I love the imagination for what they
can do with the items that's awesome
what you just did I actually think the
Shelf items look very real too yeah I
would love some wood chips
I'm gonna put Ember out of her misery
and retire huh we are we are more than
ready for you to actually buy something
if you'd ever get up off your lazy Ash
okay girl she's sashy she's real sashy
it's good because he added Ash in the
middle exactly you got it I got it and I
will read the smoke
I'm doing I'm doing reading sorry gotta
grab some stuff are we a match
true love uh I like the way the visuals
of this world make me feel like from the
characters or the world the world yeah I
don't know there's something kind of
calming about it
dad catch you out here again
[Music]
I love that
oh my queen sorry buddy elements don't
mix gotta go come on you'll never leave
this part of town oh that little guy
looks a little uh yeah stop motion
for she did a barbecue
oh oh you could do that with human
babies
laughs
Trio
some cool tracking shots in this yeah
tomorrow I sleep in and I want you to
run shop for red dots there what
whoa without losing your temper it will
show me you are able to take over
you got it ashva all right girl you
better keep it in bury your feelings
like the rest of us
I really love the way the colors bounce
off of each other and yeah on the
animation I think it's gorgeous to look
at it so beautiful yeah I agree it is
there is a little bit of separation
between the elements and the rest of the
world which kind of throws me off if
some people were bugged by the enemy I'm
not bothered by it there just is like a
little
I get what you're saying though yeah
so many stickers for sale
[Music]
Ted love these tracking shots
no did she just like blow purple and
she's gonna blow up the shop
oh god oh no this is terrible oh this is
bad
oh but the use of the powers is so cool
I agree that was awesome
look at this water and environment
that looks so real yeah is that you and
your dad
I love dads oh
my God I was searching for a link on the
other side of the river and got sucked
in I just can't seem to find my float
it's revealing I'm afraid I'm gonna have
to write you a ticket a ticket yeah I'm
a city inspector this pipe is definitely
not up to code
everything's solid I should know my dad
rebuilt this place himself well perfect
I'm gonna have to write that up too oh
god oh station's like a good display
oh boy get back here sorry I gotta get
these to City Hall before the end of my
shift oh buddy
[Music]
she's always on the verge of turning
purple
oh my goodness
I feel like he could learn to stop
leaking so much and she could learn to
control our temper and maybe they can do
it
balance each other yeah
you're gonna have to go to another town
though she doesn't do that but now she's
gotta
it's almost like she's kind of my
combination of anger and Joy from inside
out and in the guys like sadness yeah
yeah just an extremely overwrought
version of him
okay she's also like Mission Impossible
girl too
oh god
oh wow
I think there's some super creative ways
of using their elemental powers
ah herself and him reflected
oh my gosh she's gonna Set This World On
Fire yeah
awesome
oh cool you can do it you can do it yeah
get it girl oh that is so cool
that was an awesome POV of that
huh
that durburger looked good
come on guys I can't get through this
she's like I had a friend oh my God
oh sorry oh my god dude
if I'm the reason it gets shut down it
will kill him why didn't you say that
before you gotta be [__] me guy
she was literally chasing you down I
just sent them over to the processing
Department I can take you there so you
can plead your cake that is so
frustrating
lighter temper and then like like light
all of these things on fire I was about
to send them to Mrs cumulus then get
sprayed for fungus rot
been letting him down no that's personal
her dad will be nope so nope but the
main thing is that her father can't
retire with your emotions Amber
oh boy yep
so I kind of called that looks like I'm
going home early today no don't this is
why the elements don't mix I am
extremely frustrated by everything right
now
I know Amber's not human but he's kind
of hot
[Music]
it ruined Red Dot sales did he do this
oh the water guy I see you chase
um yeah you gotta be honest with your
daddy and why is Waterman pipes City
shut down years ago
these elements are gonna have to learn
to work together like inside out
there is a reason we left fire land
we put everything into it but then a
great what
oh my God
[Music]
it was the only way to create a better
life
I didn't realize there was gonna be all
this commentary on immigration yeah too
deep for me moving on
it's like immigrant Coming to America
starting your own Mom and Pop shop it's
tough and then some white boy comes
around and ruins everything for you
oh sorry
you're so hot
waiting to talk to your boss so make
like a stream and flow somewhere else
nice I just came by because I left my
passes for the game here last night
it's gonna take some work for me to
learn to love this guy yeah telling you
guys that right now I agree like off the
bat I'm like really is this gonna be the
love oh all right all right he's just uh
it's a bit frustrating I get that's the
point
where is she up there in that Sky Box
lightning
have lightning and she gets like mad so
she'll have something to teach Amber
um
[Music]
I was hoping we could work something out
come on rap are your eyes the back of
your head
literally called it do you mind there's
a game going on this is my life we're
talking about not just some game this is
the playoffs
I don't want to hear a sob story about
the problems of some little shop oh
it'll shock matters way more than a
bunch of overpaid Cloud Puffs blowing
some ball around say cloud Puffs one
more time
oh
he's doing his best
so he's just like hyper-empathetic
[Music]
super empathetic and she is angry all
the time
do the wave oh cool that's pretty cool
oh watch out
I like this reoccurring motif of taking
common phrases and terminologies and
bringing them in yeah
whoa
okay buddy there you go power of love
all right
[Applause]
oh look how he can inspire all right so
he makes like a good leader
inspirational guy I'm gonna have to take
apart your dad's shop to figure out
what's going on you can't I bet this is
connected to that fluff and leak what
the villain Amber and I could track the
water from her shop to find the source
of the leak keep talking I could call in
a city crew to fix whatever we find it's
a fair trade make that deal if you can
find the leak and get a crew to fix it
by then those tickets are forgiven if
not your dad's shop gets shut down I
feel like some of these other elements
are so cold hard there's not
cold-heartedness amongst these yeah
I don't understand I fixed one pipe and
another
oh man he he is not doing well
yes he's absolutely going to die I was
in the canals checking the doors for
leaks when I found some water that
shouldn't have been there Rusty with a
hint of motor oil motor oil has been
transported
and I got sucked into a filtering system
but then I heard this explosion
shot ah
the roof
oh awesome
oh that's so pretty
two different elements working
how can they be intimate well she can
eat those those logs while they're doing
it
and then he can wear a suit a suit I bet
just hold a water a waterproof suit
and they just say I love you at least 10
times
after my dad passed I got all what's the
point now I just go from one job to the
next there's a word in fire-ish the
shock s embrace the light while it burns
because it won't always last forever
that is a great saying I like that I
will remember it to show the credits
roll
Garden Central Station my dad took me
there because they had a vivisteria tree
the only flower that can thrive
that's neat I was
but they said our fire was too dangerous
oh couldn't go in
my dad was so angry
and embarrassed so cruel so I missed my
one chance to see a bibisteria
I was
so bad sometimes when I lose my temper I
think it's just me trying to tell me
something I'm not ready to hear yeah
I like that line This Guy's slowly
winning me over yeah he's got some good
Waters one-liners in there
motor oil Yep this is the source I do
think he cries a little too much I agree
with you 100 that would be off-putting
just like she gets too angry though too
much so like you know
there we have it
can he not survive that I mean he can he
just gets washed up with it right like
he'll just end up in a pipe again or
something like he's water he could just
like blend in firetown
oh boy
you better build that Dam and you better
do it quick
catch
yeah oh okay what happened to all those
muscles buddy
[Music]
oh there we go so he gets like he can
get like huge
good job wow there's no water leaking
through at all you've got a little
here right there
oh yeah she can't I'll make sure there's
a city crew here by Friday see ya wait
free tomorrow
to hang out with uh
water guy
oh a water guy
I'll be at the alkaline theater three
o'clock this whole problem is going away
I can feel it
girl you better get to that theater she
better not get so mad at him that he
decides not to do the city crew on
Friday and then there I mean obviously I
feel like that might happen but
uh she has to hide herself uh there he
goes again
he's crying too much rain always gonna
go next there's nothing wrong with
crying love cry I cry all the time I'm
just saying this guy is literally
leaking from his eyes in a furious way
almost all day it's a little it's a
little
oh they blend together that's cute
[Music]
they like her
oh shibi fan
mommy and daddy aren't going to approve
of this romance that's for sure but she
just didn't get angry because love heals
all wounds did you see that's what I'm
talking about yeah
they're not once they figure it out
obviously they're gonna be I don't know
where my wife is always so mad at me all
the time
[Music]
I wouldn't mind
try it oh they can't but maybe they
could
[Music]
oh my God it's so beautiful there I
can't even handle it
a new color how'd you do that
cover yourself in minerals son get to
dancing that's cool
oh my God it's like you could be with a
different woman all the time can you
change that different mineral babe
my God I love it can you paint with all
the colors of the mount
that's so pretty under the bridge oh my
god get doused in love
oh boy
yeah man I mean
you were curious that there was yeah no
water leaking before
oh
foreign
[Music]
what are you doing here I got bad news
you knocked over three tons of cement
dust half
I still have a cup
still have hard feelings because they
won't help us wait nobody pods you are
city inspector uh no I am not an
inspector
huh I've come to inspect your food yep
oh it's good to me no no no no inspect
with your mouth dude you know what would
happen you mean you know he's water he
can't be doing it I mean he's just gonna
boil up inside
oh God whoa
[Music]
you must try these straight from
Firelands what are you doing
uh you have to have three oh my goodness
oh okay
see it's really tasty if you water it
down a little water was down water us
down oh God then water no longer allowed
in shop
it's okay he's terrifying yeah
I think I'm failing
whoa hi ashfa should have retired years
ago but he doesn't think I'm ready what
is happening to her how do you repay a
sacrifice that big it all feels like a
burden how can I say that oh my gosh
she's coming to the truth of her
emotions maybe you're right when you
said my temper is me trying to tell me
something look what your fire did to the
sand
glass
you could do
[Music]
damn no GLA glass water uh where are you
going with this like a really thick
glass wall I know how to steal those
doors yeah you know you make the sand
glass thick glass some water can't get
through crystallize it yeah yeah like
the attack on Titan anime
[Music]
there you go all right nice
look at them empowering each other
wow I've just never been punched in the
face with beauty before you can swallow
all that hot food
is it gonna hold it worked save this for
you it's special
oh my God they might be able to
fear changing you happier armor with
customers and with that food and she's
been letting love wash over her wow
oh my God
Love Is in the Air
unit and tired at the truth that you're
in love with water boy okay
before he dies and then he never knows
the truth yeah man who's she sniffing it
out she knows what's up sometimes you
just gotta follow your heart and go with
the flow
[Music]
wow Gregory
for a bit
oh no
I just didn't know she
'd be buzzings the rest of the family
oh God how's she gonna how are you gonna
do you have a floaty for her how's this
gonna work create a glass okay thank you
floaty yeah
I don't understand the rules of how they
don't set everything on fire tell you
that he's deathly afraid of sponges no I
was traumatized
interesting flashbacks with this guy
yeah oh oh yeah
what race is Ember supposed to be
riffing off right well any I can fix it
oh there we go Amber
I think like any and all
underrepresented Races big encompasses
all of them Middle East Asia Africa
whoa that's so pretty can someone please
actually make that in real life I would
buy it that wasn't
so supported by this a creative family
every building in the new city is built
from just melted glass that's
foreign
maybe after dinner The Crying Game oh
boy we try not to cry oh that's a real
YouTube challenge
1979. November you were
I
butterfly windshield wipers half a
butterfly
when I met you
you as whole
of the Water Works gonna come from
everyone and all I want now is to be
near it
that is so sweet
together
activate the tears
oh that is so ethereal ethereal and
beautiful yin and yang
it's gonna run away she can cry
oh
you repaired it with glass
glass solid as a rock consider the
tickets canceled
okay I have a friend who runs the best
glass making firm in the world and I
told her about you what about the Mom
and Pop Shop fireplace an amazing
opportunity for real it's a long way
from the city but it wouldn't be an
incredible start my mom was just trying
to be helpful oh my God this is not this
is not good she's gonna get she's gonna
blow purple I don't think I
want to run the shop what what that's
what my temper has been trying to tell
me oh
Oh I thought she really did one yeah
because like as a kid I guess it was
them putting their their dreams on her
this place is
cheers
be a common theme in Pixar these days of
I don't want to live in my parents
Shadow at all the writers and animators
are working through some [__]
you must light these with your fire and
I read the smoke
oh no he's gonna prove him wrong
foreign
[Music]
looks like a union might look like an
infinity sign in the Smoke to me I'm too
excited to sleep in two days I retired
oh oh
no we're going to throw a big party a
grand reopening that way I can tell the
whole world my daughter take over I'm
not gonna lie I didn't really see the
conflict she was having about not
wanting to run the shop no it came out
of left field I guess it was Aaron she
was really excited every time we would
give her the opportunity it was never
like met with like a Gruff the Box Soul
the big bow it is the highest form of
respect
but my father did not return the bow so
I have this this made for you oh God
the pressure it's too much we unveiled
it a great reopening
come Bernie you need your rest Amber
just push her feelings down yeah and
just stick to the plan it's so weird
that like it's gonna be out of left
field for her parents too that she never
even said anything she just didn't
realize about it she never realized I
get okay so it's like she just had it
hidden and just went with the flow yeah
she never okay that was her oh here we
go you came all the way here to give it
to me oh no no no no
no way breaking into
wait is the water the dam is gonna break
and the water goes through so maybe she
won't have to run the shop thinking too
far ahead Focus do you still want to see
a vivisteria the air should last at
least 20 minutes why does
I just tell you what you can do in your
life oh
this is starting to really get to my
heart right now
cool
get in there awesome
that's really creative that's awesome
that's really beautiful it's like an
underground city
[Music]
don't break up with him don't you do it
girl that's beautiful though wow you get
the ultimate View
[Music]
oh
wow that's gorgeous I think the dialogue
in this movie could be better but they
rely on this the visual storytelling
components it is I think it is firing on
all cylinders I agree a 10 out of 10.
yeah see we're running out of hair
go faster hold your breath Amber
decisions yeah
[Music]
no
wait wait we can't touch Maybe
yeah like why won't you even try I could
vaporize you you could distinguish me
and then
start small
a light touch it's just like West Side
Story man
whoa gnarly
oh it was okay
oh my God
whoa what oh my God yes
ah
wow
oh that is a beautiful illustration it's
like their energy atomic particle levels
are converging this is so gorgeous
now try oh they're intertwined
see all you had to do was try
that's so sweet and it's so beautiful
what is she gonna do
just tell your father how you feel maybe
he'll agree you're just afraid you're
just chicken [__] I'm I'm fire it's what
I am and what my family is it's our way
of life I cannot throw all of that away
just for you you don't know what it's
like to be first generation man I'm
first generation and you're so messed up
as a result I know I make internet
videos it's so sad I could have been a
doctor yeah it could have been anything
else honestly I am so proud to have you
take over my life's work
looks like she's committed yeah Lantern
I bring from Old Country I pass it on to
you what are you doing here you said me
not understanding is the reason we can
never work this is his run to the
airport moment you're fire on water I
mean come on that's crazy right
this
hmm we touched and when we did something
happen to us we changed each other's
chemistry really it's a guy who burst
into your daughter's life in a flooded
old basement so you are the one who
burst a pipe what not me it was you
oh dude Your Love Speech condom boy you
don't have forever to say what you need
to say I love you Amber Lumen oh and I'm
pretty sure you love me too no Wade I
don't got to credits oh boy
that's not true I did their reading I
don't love you
oh God okay
trusted you you
over the shop
oh thank God
this damn just keeps breaking through
well there goes that it really should
have taken more preventative measures
yeah I'm just gonna say it wasn't built
well in the first place
Dairy slave let me go
she'll get it
oh boy personalization yeah come on come
on come on use the sand put the glass
back up
oh there we go finally
no no no no no no no no
no no
I'm not going anywhere
uh you're gonna you're gonna uh
[Music]
oh you can put the little light in there
and run oh
that is that's all right
oh yeah nice
oh boy oh God is he gonna boil up I have
to open that up no the water will come
in and you'll be snuffed out with your
evaporating I don't know what to do oh
it's okay no it's not
wait no no no you gave me something
people search for their whole lives
I can't exist in a world without you I'm
sorry I didn't say it before Oh her
tears can help him live I love you Wade
right
really do love it when your light bust
that
is so sweet I don't want it no
what's gonna happen hey they both died
there's no way
is gone
I I don't really
I'm liking so disbelief over this
situation right now did they really just
do that I
I'm a shop
the shop was never the dream you
murdered dreams to be happy
loved him dad
no there's a puddle oh thank God great
thank God he's in a puddle in the ground
crying right
butterfly
windshield wipers half butterfly he
cries he comes back
[Music]
an old man on his deathbed remembers the
summary
that's great
or just say something to make father guy
cry okay you are no longer packed banned
[Music]
your uh chimney needs cleaning
yes yeah come on oh see
they can't exist and everyone sees it
now
interracial love
oh yeah what would their baby look like
deformed
just a bowl of boiling water
hey
Amber
it's time oh they going they're leaving
oh is she gonna go build glass oh God
Stark New Life your mother and I will be
here now with more time for hanky-panky
[Music]
if I take one step it'll be the furthest
from the Shire I've ever been she's
gonna
show some emotion
the biggest Bell
honor your heritage
that was so sweet it kind of made me cry
[Music]
she gave to her dad what his dad could
never give to him
yeah
oh that was really that was sweet it was
really touching ending yeah yeah
I like this movie I liked it a lot it
was great it's so colorful and
fun and cool it took me a minute to warm
up to it no but did you hear that what
happened
to it I did a pun or a thing I did a
thing
and didn't even realize I was doing oh
my God yep you're a Poe you don't even
know it yeah well that's me
what did you think you loved it or what
I liked it a lot I loved parts of it
yeah I'm figuring out what is not making
me I guess I I think that the the actual
progression of the story it lands in a
fantastic spot it took me a while to
like Wade which is kind of the point
because you're in Amber's perspective
yep
which I appreciated I do think
I guess it's there not sure I think it
would have helped at least for me maybe
we're just in the minority here I I I I
I I really couldn't tell that she wanted
nothing to do with absolutely not we are
not in the minority they gave us nothing
to tell us that she would be against it
every time he said take over the shop
she would be really excited and be like
oh really like she wouldn't be like oh
and I think of alluding to that a bit
earlier on would have helped
Aid some of that might have made it more
predictable than it already was but but
I still think it would have helped
probably with
the conflict and the emotional Journey
so that way when you are watching
certain events unfold you are feeling
some of the tension to some of these
events like her falling in love with
Wade her with the glass abilities and
having a different creative Pursuit you
know like so that way the conflict is a
little bit more apparent yeah through
that first like hour of the film totally
you know because but even when it wasn't
like rooted so much in conflict and
whatever as a conflict was the you know
I have to save the shot because of this
disaster situation I have caused and we
have to fix this whole the whole
literally fix the hole yeah yeah
um so I so I understand that uh but
you're talking more the internal
conflict which is the thing you really
latch on to and so much of it was caught
up in like some more of that physical
stuff that I think it would have helped
root it I think that's what I'm trying
to get to is it just would have helped
root it more into that
um internal emotional Conflict for that
first hour but the maybe it is just the
the physical experience of it where at
times you can it everything just even
though it's the elements feel more
animated than a lot of their environment
that they are inhabiting I still was
getting washed over uh yeah
the the uh The Ether the well there was
such an atmosphere about it that I did
find so sweet and a heartwarming and
very cute throughout that I just enjoyed
the mood and Aura of it so much that I
even with the things that were like ah
yeah this could have been like a little
better structure and the dialogue could
have been better overall
uh I I was still very much I still very
much liked it a lot I yeah yeah it's
like the vibe of the environment was
really cool like it gave off a really
good vibe and I was sort of thinking
about the characters how I initially
said in the beginning I'm it's like the
environment was so realistic and their
animation kind of I was like yeah I get
why maybe people aren't drawn to it
right away and then I think I realized
because they had to make them look that
way because they had to have the
elements be able to so that you could
see reflection so that you could see him
eat an ember and see it go through his
body because initially I was kind of
wondering why they didn't make it look
like a character and that he was just
like crying a lot and like kind of water
on the outside but looked more like a
Pixar face yeah yeah you know and like
her for fire but then you wouldn't be
able to use all the shots that they used
yeah that's just seeing the things move
through him or her as fire and water
yeah yeah so I mean I can't think of the
last time we saw a Pixar story and maybe
I'm just completely blanking that was a
love story
am I breaking on something there well
normally they're not just like a direct
guy and girl falling in love bit of a
Romeo and Juliet West Side Story
different cultures yeah you're right I
mean except for the beginning of up
which will make you SOB until next year
um but it's not a story about people
falling right I agree I agree
um yeah I mean I guess
yeah you're right I don't know I like
that traditional sense of it there's
there's something very traditional about
its storytelling yeah and yeah I mean
predictability is aside like whatever uh
though by the time they get to the end
the the emotion like I was run over by
Wayne by the end of that I really like
this guy when he was dead I I was like
did they just do that I was kind of
surprised yeah if they had just let him
die I would have been like really in
shock like what the hell did this movie
just do uh yeah so there that quality
was good and
I do think yeah just the emotional
storytelling of it could have been
better yeah fleshed out and I the movie
really shines when they're not actually
relying on dialogue then when it's not
doing yeah when it's just showing you
the elements what they're moving through
how beautiful the shots were that made
me feel more than any of the dialogue
yes which is funny because like Pixar is
like really normally I mean this is
still a great film like there was a
great there were some great one-liners I
don't remember the thing but it's like
just be happy that the Ember is there
because it won't always last very long
it wasn't those exact words but I did
really like that one line there was
another one but to me in my head it's
always like Pixar is like this perfect
writing that knows how to write in
certain emotional moments that really
can get to you uh especially at the end
that like you're sort of like oh yeah
yeah right and this I didn't get that
way maybe that was completely their
intention
um maybe it was just to like throw us
off the scent of everything in the
beginning meaning like yeah we didn't we
didn't realize it all kind of came out
of left field for I guess all all of us
like her not wanting to be in the shop
and then
yeah I don't I don't know I but that's
probably better story writing so we
didn't see it coming but still have you
seen uh
turning red yes
so that was another one about different
culture and
I don't want to live in my parents yes I
feel like there's another one out there
that I'm not pinpointing right now I'm
sure there's a lot I mean I feel like
but I think that's been like a common
thing in animation always and it's
interesting of like artists growing up
and and then they step into animation
and and then they're using this
storyline this storytelling Motif to
communicate that and
there's nothing wrong with that message
and right the way it's handled here is
not like the dad is a bad person sure is
Stern and whatever yeah but he's not a
bad person I never once got the
impression like this guy's way out of
line and he's abusive or some [__] like
I never thought that uh but it is I just
find it interesting how that is a
reoccurring thing that maybe we could
find a different theme to be using to be
yeah to be yeah I agree
um I want to look up some recent Pixar
movies that is a very calming common
thing honestly yeah and I I just can't
let this video thank you Mom and Dad for
all the sacrifice that was gonna make me
cry what's that at the end I don't know
with deep appreciation to all those who
help us burn brightly but that makes me
cry and that and I'm glad we we just saw
that moment especially I mean not just
honor but as as it being one of the main
themes of Snow White with parents who
come to yeah from the different lantives
give their children an opportunity you
know
um it's like a very it's a very it this
movie I think their theme meant to be
more like teaching you about different
cultures and how you can get stuck in
your world when you come to America
because you're like this is safety and
we don't mix because when we do it's
scary and people are judgmental and
they'll they'll rain down on us in a way
in a negative light
um and then she was exposed to a bright
light with a family who accepted her was
excited to like meet her and with Wade
right but I still think you are right in
what you were saying that like it it is
show honor to the people who sacrificed
a lot to bring their family somewhere to
open up a dream for the family and to
like carry it on to so they could all
have a better life which is a sweet
sentiment yeah yeah and I think with a
lot of like Latino culture Asian culture
Miss Middle East culture as well Indian
culture there's there's so many of like
first people like our age well not yours
you're like 20 years older than me right
um
I could just never yeah I'm 1965. yeah
45. so there's um there's there's like
I'm first my mom's side uh I I'm on my
mom's I'm first generation uh Filipino
on my Italian side I'm not first
generation there's like
some I think my great grandpa was the
first generation the grandpa the grand
my grandpa was the first generation if
I'm not mistaken so
um but in my circle growing up like
there was a most of my friends
who were not white uh were all first
generation Latino Asian primarily were
the the races I I I'm referring to right
and you do see a lot of that pressure I
I would like my mom actually never
really gave him how much I always wanted
me on top of my money in taxes that's
all everyone really cared about but
career fursuit she's actually been
really
um uh well Frugal
uh she she just lets you kind of do
whatever I want which has been great
about her but I see that so much in the
other cultures as well out here that
that can be a thing where you really
want to honor your parents in that it's
not just a cultural thing too you can
see it in all in white people as well
sure right and I'm saying that
out I really identified with that with
witnessing that I see it with some of my
family members on my cousin's side and
whatever and then also with a lot of
friends who do feel that pressure to
uphold uh the Pursuits of what their
parents ultimately want them to do and
to also find love within your race yeah
that's a very common thing it's like
important it's it's still very much out
there it's a real thing that happens and
I think getting that across is not a is
a good thing to be like no yeah yeah
make your own choices it's nice to see
one where the parents are also being
supportive as well and so yeah I could
have said that more eloquently I know I
could have I was kind of stumbling over
my no I mean I get whenever I touch on
racism I was like I get a little bit uh
like if I I don't want to say too much
because I want then I'm going to feel
like I'm over explaining myself and then
I don't want to say too little because
then I feel like I didn't explain it
yeah and then I just kind of stumbled my
way through it because I got too caught
up in my own head there but I think you
guys know what I'm still going to go now
I'm explaining why I explained yeah yeah
that's always a great we did a whole
thing yeah listen what I was going to
say is that one time I watched a reality
show at a friend's house the girl was
like it was 90 days fiance or something
where they have to go meet like the
person but she was specifically asking
she was like my priority is that he is
also Jewish or whatever she was saying
that is just such a
it is very important to a lot of
families and I'm like we would have I
get it because there's certain elements
of that you're like well I just want
them to be in the same race or in the
same culture because then we understand
things better yeah but I'm like yeah but
like if you opened it up a little bit
more who knows what you could find yeah
and I think what the movie's trying to
say is that if if you are one of those
people who does
like I don't fault someone if if they're
like I'm Armenian I want to marry
another Armenian not at all I'm like I
got you yeah don't worry about it it's
if you've what the movie's trying to say
is yeah if you happen to fall in love
yeah or like someone who's outside of
that yeah and you're only going to
choose a partner due to satisfy your
parents yeah don't do that yeah maybe
maybe don't do that don't do that follow
your heart man wherever you go try to at
least try to at least try to or just
like definitely do you know I know Tara
is 70 still pursuing acting yeah
auditioning left and right hey I gotta I
gotta I gotta film a commercial on
Friday okay so you know and then next
week I'm filming a feature film it
sounds crazy that you get to do these
roles where like oh you're a hospice
care patient exactly and and I have to
just stand there and I feed I feed
somebody soup
um for sure I thought you were being fed
the soup but I remember that incorrectly
well you just set me up as someone who's
in the hospital I just figured I thought
Oh I thought yeah I'm the old person
getting getting the soup
it flew right over my head it flew and
it went into the other room and I was
like we'll do a bit and then it really
it exploded well as it went into Embers
as you get older you know naturally you
your sharpness you lose your weight yeah
you lose your wit and your grit and your
talent apparently that's what Greg's
been telling me ever since
so yeah
um welp uh I guess you guys can let me
know in the comments if you think I'm
too old to keep following my dreams and
you can let Greg know should I try to
explain the race thing again
no definitely I don't think I think in
the comments you you just it can like
break notes I think if you wait for a
third time explaining it whether you
would like it or not and then when we
come back for another film he can
continue Despicable Me 3.
yeah it'll be our intro
he would like to really give it a third
try because he explained it once and
then explained his explanation and now
here we are still talking about it you
know because it's it's Gregory Alba and
that's what he does huh well who close
this out Tara okay listen you guys give
us a like and a comment tell us what you
want us to watch next but also tell us
how did you like this movie how did you
like the animation did you also fall in
love with everything else surrounding
them because this world was so pretty
and if Disneyland doesn't build like a
little world that looks a little bit
like this I might be upset because it's
so beautiful it's so fluffy
that's from Despicable Me one and I love
that line so much okay
um that's all we love you so much and
goodbye
Korea Korea watch that's what it says
it's based I didn't get that at all this
is based on Korea Korea's variety is
saying reflected the Immigrant story
reflect the administer of Korea to New
York City
I didn't get that but maybe they were
just trying to make it all in one okay
reflective of what he is his story they
weren't doing Taekwondo so I couldn't
they weren't eating noodles so they
weren't eating they weren't eating
Barbies Ramen right Korean barbecue I
was like I was in ramen no it's not it's
not and then I thought like nude and
then I was gonna say bok choy
bok choy Korean like in a lot in
let me try to explain the race you
should really it's a racist thing
you really should have caught before you
yelled Korea okay uh who who
um what's his name who's editing this
it's
prepper prepper prepper prepper can cut
this I actually control this part of the
video it's ending now
foreign